meghan markle and prince harry are
keeping the royal family
up to date on their newborn daughter
lillabet et has learned that the couple
who welcomed baby lily earlier this
month
shared all the info about their daughter
with their family members
shortly after her birth how well through
the royal family's whatsapp group chat
where extended family members
often stay in touch it's a big deal the
news comes shortly after lilly's aunt
kate middleton
expressed excitement over the newborn's
arrival your royal highness
do you have any wishes for your new
niece a little bit
oh i wish her all the very best i can't
wait to meet her
while the 39 year old royal paid a visit
to a school in the united kingdom last
week
kate spoke out for the first time about
baby lily i can't wait to meet her
attendees were also curious whether kate
had met her in real life or virtually
we haven't yet um yet met her yet so
hopefully
that will be soon
et has also learned that the duchess of
cambridge is keeping the peace within
the royal family
it's always been my understanding that
behind the scenes
kate has tried very hard to forge a
reproduction
and act as a peacemaker between william
and harry
you know she loves harry he said she is
the sister that he never had
she's been heartbroken to see them fall
out and i think she is one of the very
few
people one of the few family members who
was actually
able to push the brothers together which
you know she did in a very subtle way
but it was very effective the source
explains that she has stepped in to help
smooth her husband prince william and
prince harry's relationship
such exciting news kate whom harry has
always been close with
realizes the importance of maintaining
their brotherly bond and she will do
whatever is necessary to be a peacemaker
between the duke of sussex and
other royal family members of course
there's been tension in the monarchy
ever since harry and megan stepped down
as senior members of the royal family
last year
and following their bombshell interview
with oprah winfrey in march
but thankfully things have been looking
up for the royal family lately it's
magic it's pretty amazing carrie's
father prince charles recently spoke
publicly about his new granddaughter for
the first time too
while visiting the bmw mini factory in
oxford england
the development of technology like
electric vehicles
or green hydrogen for that matter for
heavy transport
is vital for maintaining the health of
our world
for future generations something i'm
only
too aware of today having recently
become a grandfather for the fifth time
and such happy news really does remind
while of the necessity of continued
innovation
in this area especially around
sustainable
battery technology in view of the legacy
we bequeath to our grandchildren
ultimately it seems like the royal
family is hopeful that baby lily can
heal the rift
this family division has really gone on
for
a very long time now it's well over a
year it's been
many many months since charles the queen
indeed the cambridges have seen
archie in the flesh and we know that
there have been
some really quite deep problems between
harry and william
difficulties between harry and his
father and i think it's everyone's
hope that this little baby will will be
a peace offering
in many ways and that she will help to
bring this divided family
back together